nous raconte qui sodomise des petites
filles de 14 ans 15 ans que ces petites
filles sont folles de lui on sait bien
que des petites filles peuvent être
folles d'un monsieur qui a une certaine
oral littéraire d'ailleurs on sait que
les vieux monsieur attirent les
petits-enfants avec des bonbons monsieur
mazeneuve lui les attirent avec sa
réputation mais ce que l'on ne sait pas
c'est comment ces petites filles de 14
ou 15 ans qui ont subi ce que l'on
appelle dans les rapports entre des
adultes et les jeunes un abus de pouvoir
commence en sorte-t-elle ces petites
filles après coup je vous interdis de
porter des jugements de ce genre de
jugement d'abord parce qu'un livre c'est
une écriture c'est un ton c'est un
univers qui attend ne peut pas servir
d'énergie même à la littérature il n'y a
pas de limite je crois que si monsieur
était plutôt un employé anonyme de
n'importe quelle société je crois qu'il
y aurait des comptes à rendre avec la
justice